hello so the candidates tournament has
started now
they played six rounds and I thought
well let's let's talk a bit about what's
happened there so far and I feel that
it's easier to do that in a video than
in YouTube now I mean in the Twitter
post or our Facebook post and with me I
have Espen understand who's who is my
manager of course who does all the dirty
work and he used to be a pretty good
chess player himself he he was at some
point 2450 now he claims to be 2,400
he's not quite 2,400 it's a bit same as
a goal for he claims to be handicapped
ten but really he's not but what's your
impression thank you very nice so what's
what's your thoughts on the candidates
there I've been pretty fighting chess
some very exciting games and are you
surprised by what weight has gone so far
not particularly I think also in the
last candidates tournament there was
there was a lot of fighting chess
obviously there there was the factor
that I was playing Aronian was playing
and we had a really good start both of
us after six rounds two both had plus
three and so the others kind of needed
to win a lot of games and that
automatically led to fighting chess and
this time they're just going at it from
from the start and that's even though
it's just cool to see it's just two
players on a plus course or four I guess
yeah now today things changed quite a
bit
okay sweet sweeter has played pretty
well so far
he claimed that he was very lucky
against Apollo well he didn't play the
opening very well but I thought from
there on he played Maria energetically
he did of course lose to do our own yawn
but that can that can happen to everyone
but today his play was was not so great
but um I'm really impressed by by what
Anand has done done so far
of course his win against Aronian was
very good very very good technique with
almost only by technique which is really
rare against Ronan and Irina didn't I
mean he didn't take it lightly in the
sense that he just gave up in a bad
position he spent all his time trying
desperately to find counter chances but
anon had some very nice maneuvers
maneuvering his Bishop from dd4 to d2
and there's other Bishop to f1 clearing
space for the road kids one it was very
very beautiful to watch and also his
game with Mama DRF was very very
impressive where he where he just played
very very powerfully after he lost in
the opening and just played very
powerfully each move no waiting move
each move had had its point and he just
took over all the key squares very
quickly I think Aaron's games have been
really tough fights yeah Rania and also
also not you know you against Kramnik he
went for it went for one of the most
complicated lines in the opening I don't
know exactly how much in you but it's
it's yes he has a good mind against
again the game against amount I Kramnik
and
but and also I was even impressed with
this game against Andre King for he she
just played very very good sound chess
from he got normal perhaps slightly
worse position from the opening and then
she just she just gradually outplayed
under a king he didn't get serious
winning chances but he was clear who was
playing the better chess in that do you
think you should have played in the
competition
I mean I don't really understand why you
offer to draw quite yet but but there
was there was nothing much much there if
you haven't taken away f3 I don't know I
think I thought the most likely scenario
then would be that the CMV pawns as well
as the rooks with the exchange and then
and then you can sort of play for a
while put your Bishop on d5 which
controls the whole board and try and
push on the King side it's very very
far-fetched and this is honestly it's
not very typical of an on to look for
those little little things if there's
nothing substantial there he usually
prefers a clearer route also I think
Kramnik today yeah obviously that was a
blow for him
pretty much money has such a good
position yesterday against Iranian and
they can convert and then losing yeah
but it's it's it's one of the things
that you need to be good at in chess and
I think it's one of the things that I do
very well it's two you always need to
adjust to the new circumstances you
cannot let what happened earlier in the
game or in the game before you cannot
let it affect you to such
a degree I think today Kramnik splay was
perhaps too emotional to and it was just
it was he wasn't psychologically ready
for this game to be honest tupolev plays
very well I mean typologies he's a very
good player he showed enterprising
preparation today and also yesterday and
today he he followed it up by playing
very well it's for Russians in the
tournament but they need to on the bus
car that's karaoke hasn't gotten it it's
going sober I mean he's very solid
chronic played a very very good game
against him and one and the other games
have been fairly normal draw so I don't
I don't think it's it's likely that
he'll make a comeback but what do you
think now played six rounds now and it's
a long tournament it's so tiring it's
fourteen rounds to remember I'm tired
you know yeah last year you think the
tournament will be decided I think so
I think I still think the only candidate
for being a runaway winner is is Aronian
if he doesn't catch fire I mean if he
had won today against under 18 which I I
think he should I think you should at
some point I don't I don't think his
technique was good enough today and I
think I don't have to explain that to
him I think he he feels that very much
himself that he should have try he
should have been able to create more
today if he had won today he would have
been a definite candidate for for
running away with the tournament now I
don't think so I think it's going to go
down to to the wire and it could well
bleed be you know that plus 3s and
to win like it was last time but the one
key lesson we learned last time is that
anything can happen in the last round
when people get tired the the usual
rules they don't look like so I rest
night tomorrow and then then they're
wrong again so we look forward to the
rest it's really exciting stuff going on
there yeah
again I'm enjoying it both us as a chess
fan and as as a professional and and the
opponent of one of these guys in the in
the world championship match so it's a
great show and yeah I think we need to
grab some food now man - so maybe we
should think about saving yeah I mean
I've said I've said everything that I
need to say and more so goodbye and um
and we'll talk later